à nevers où pierre bérégovoy avait
vaquer à ses occupations de maire d hier
matin rien ne laissait présager un tel
drame la ville en deuil
isabelle thomas nevers s'est éveillée ce
matin sous une pluie incessante un ciel
de deuil
à l'image d'une ville entière plongé
dans la stupeur et l'émotion qui à
bérégovoy était maire de nevers depuis
dix ans aujourd'hui les drapeaux de
l'hôtel de ville sont en berne
sincèrement ça m'a fait un choc comme si
j'avais perdu quelqu'un de ma famille on
aimait bien vous savez ici à nevers peu
importe la politique c'était assez son
bonheur je pense qu'on fait mais pour le
rca dh réélu député de la nièvre en mars
dernier puis à bérigaud vous avez reçu
le matin même des syndicalistes la
région pour parler des problèmes du
chômage n'est pas différent ils étaient
ils étaient quand même
il était marqué par
le peu le peu de personnes présentes à
ces manifestations
aujourd'hui tout le monde s'interroge
ses proches bien sûr sont les premiers à
douter je pense que la formule a
actuellement beau père il ne pouvait pas
admettre il ne pouvait pas supporter que
sont m étais puisse être mise en cause
et si les interrogations ne manquent pas
un hiver l'heure est aujourd'hui à la
stupeur et au chagrin
vous vous expliquer cette se suicident
comment je n'explique pas
j'explique pas un suicide